Transcriber:
I have a question for you.
How would you have coped
with the COVID-19 pandemic
if you'd had no access to the internet?
March 2020.
I know we all want to forget,
but allow me to take you
back to March 2020.
You see, it felt like one minute
we were doing what we always do,
going about our daily business,
and then we were keeping, sort of,
one eye on a virus that was over there.
And then the next day, boom,
we were in a head-on collision
with a pandemic
that nobody knew what to do about.
Authorities jumped to action.
Don't go to church,
don't go to the mosque,
don't see your friends,
don't go to restaurants, don't go outside,
don't use public transport
and don't visit your parents,
don't go to school,
don't go to work.
It was a barrage of "don'ts"
from every direction possible.
It was a lot.
But we adapted.
We started to accept,
and slowly we shifted more
and more of what we did
from in-person to online.
We started to rely
on the power of the internet
to order our groceries online,
to order our meals,
to speak to our friends
or even to learn how to take care
of that plant, finally.
We used the internet to pray.
We used it to exercise, to meditate,
to speak to our therapists.
Organizations, including the one
that I work with,
shifted to remote working
and I was able to continue working.
Some schools figured out
how to deliver online classes,
and my children only had three weeks
of interruption to their learning
before they were back in class online.
Granted, they were in these classes
wearing a school shirt and a school tie
with pajama bottoms,
but I couldn't do anything about it
because I was doing
pretty much the same thing
in my Zoom meetings.
Unfortunately, this picture
that I've painted
was not the same for everyone.
It certainly wasn't true for those
without access to the internet.
The lady who helps us
with our chores in the house
talked to me about her rising
levels of anxiety
as she saw more and more
of her friends lose their jobs.
Her friends who sold in markets,
who sold at street corners,
they had no customers
and therefore no money
because we were all sheltering in place.
While she saw my children sitting
in their Zoom classes
talking to their teachers,
her own children
had to be taken to the village.
Because, you see,
with all the parents out
trying to make some money
and no school for the kids to go to,
their safety and security
was no longer guaranteed.
So the village was their only option.
In my own home village of Kasama
in rural Zambia,
a beautiful and brilliant
young girl named Chomba
faces the exact same fate
of not being able
to continue her education.
Because, you see, they don’t have
access to the internet.
And the longer the pandemic rages on,
the further and further and further away
her dream of becoming
a medical doctor go,
and the higher her chances become
of becoming a teenage mum
or getting married off as a teenager.
Many of us use the internet
for so many things,
even if it was just talking
to our parents on video calls.
And we did so without a second thought
to those without internet.
Did it ever cross your mind how they,
those without internet, were coping?
We live in a digital age
where access to the internet
is no longer a nice-to-have;
it is a definite must-have.
The internet provides a tool for us
to engage in democratic conversations.
We have a voice in spaces
that were previously
a preserve of the few,
whereas before only those
who could go to TV stations,
radio stations that have access
to newspaper interviews had a say,
now everybody can speak
about issues that affect them.
Just in the last few years,
we have seen the power of the internet
used to connect people
from across the world.
People who don't even speak
each other's languages
have been able to rally together
to fight against things
like racism, sexism,
climate change and so much more.
And globally, over two billion people
do not have access to the internet.
Two billion.
So why should that number
of two billion people concern you?
As I mentioned, the internet
gives power to people
to contribute to their economies,
to contribute to politics
and to social issues.
Let me put the economic
contribution into context.
My home country of Zambia
relies on agriculture.
We place a lot of emphasis
on agriculture, and rightly so.
Because 60 percent
of the Zambian population
relies on agriculture
for their livelihoods.
That’s according to United
Nations statistics.
And yet, when we look at the numbers,
agriculture contributes only 7.5 percent
to the country’s GDP most years.
So 60 percent of the population
is relying on something
that contributes 7.5 percent to the GDP.
In contrast,
data from 2019 showed
that one developed nation
was able to get 10 percent
of its GDP contribution
from the power of the internet,
not technology more broadly,
the internet.
Can you imagine what would happen
if more people had access to the internet?
And lest we forget,
access to the internet
would give Chomba in my home village
the right to learn.
She would be able to go to school
and get closer to realizing her dream
of contributing to the health sector.
We need to act now.
We need to actively
and collectively ensure
that going forward,
everyone has access to a free,
fair and feminist internet.
We cannot afford to look away
simply because we are comfortable
and we have access.
Because we need the contribution
of the two billion.
We need them contributing
to the economies of our countries.
We need their voices in politics.
We need their voices on social issues.
Now, I'll be the first to admit
that this is not a small task.
What I'm proposing, an equitable internet,
is a major undertaking,
but we have to start somewhere.
We need governments
and development partners
to start to acknowledge
that digital rights
in a digital era are important
to every citizen of their countries:
policies that encourage competition
among technology providers;
regulation that allows
for low-cost energy solutions
to penetrate even where
it’s hard to reach;
changes to school curricula
to include digital literacy;
and free internet
to the lowest-income citizens.
All those are just a starting point.
But we also understand
that with the world's
economy slowing down,
most of our governments
will not prioritize digital access.
Most of them will default
to the traditional election winners:
those infrastructure projects
that are outdated
before they are even completed.
They will focus on those,
and those projects only
benefit the middle class
and the upper class,
leaving the poorer even further behind.
But this is where the private sector,
non-profits and foundations come in.
They certainly have the technical skills,
the expertise and the financial resources
to ensure that every citizen
has access to the internet.
And we need to start holding
global corporations to account.
In 2020, we learned
that at least 20 developing countries
were missing out on as much
as 2.8 billion dollars in tax revenue
from just three big tech companies.
Three.
This is only a tip of the iceberg
because we know there are a lot
of companies operating in these locations,
but due to unfair global tax rules,
they're not giving back their fair share.
We need to demand
that they start to give back.
And give back in a way
that is sustainable,
that is genuine and does not come
with the conditions
that they normally attach to anything
that they consider "free"
in this context.
And to ensure sustainability,
it can be as simple as starting to look
at what has already been tested
in terms of providing access
to technologies,
bringing those up to the surface
and then working with communities
to make sure that whatever is put in place
is for the long term --
and not just for the immediate.
One thing we can all agree on
is that there are definitely enough
internet resources to go around,
and the technology
is certainly advanced enough
to make sure that everybody has access.
We need to figure out how we bring
these resources together
so that Chomba in my village does not
just have access to learning content
that is relevant to her,
but that she's also able to take part
in economic discussions,
in political discourse
and making sure that she has
access to an internet
where she is protected
from online abuses such as surveillance,
intimidation and bullying.
On [an] individual level, you and I,
those of us with access,
need to stand with those that don't have.
We need to make sure
that we are not leaving
those two billion behind
and that we are making sure
they have access
to all the tools they need
to live up to their full potential.
So knowing how an equitable internet
benefits the collective,
how will you contribute
to reducing that two billion number?